there was an almost surreal quality to
Donald Trump's victory a billionaire
businessman turned champion of the
working people sweeping to power
stunning the nation and the world
but having run one of the most
controversial and divisive presidential
campaigns in modern American history
Trump in his triumph struck a unifying
tone
now it's time for America to bind the
wounds of division have to get together
to all Republicans and Democrats and
independents across this nation I say it
is time for us to come together as one
United people style to Forgotten men and
women of our country will be forgotten
no longer and so America asks what's
next for now the conventional
choreography of the peaceful transition
of power has kicked in Donald Trump woke
up to congratulations from world leaders
and an invitation from President Barack
Obama to the White House from the
President to the president-elect a clear
rather hopeful message we try really
hard to persuade people that we're right
and then people vote and then if we lose
we learn from our mistakes we do some
reflection we lick our wounds we brush
ourselves off we get back in the arena
we go at it we try even harder the next
time for the Republicans it was also
time to forge ahead to rally behind the
man who once caused them such anguish I
think what Donald Trump just pulled off
is an enormous political feat it's an
enormous feat in that he heard those
voices that were out there that other
people weren't hearing and he just
earned a mandate the Trump was propelled
to victory in large part by anger and
contempt for Washington he promised the
white working-class voters who backed
him
that he would destroy the old order of
things return prosperity remake the
broken American dream in Michigan Ohio
Pennsylvania and elsewhere they are
expecting great things think outside the
box and make our country great again for
the millions who didn't vote for Trump
this is a journey into the unknown in
New York his hometown there's anxiety we
had a moment
history
I think it's terrifying I think both
economically and socially it kind of
sucks but at the same time you know we
have a saying over here it is what it is
others are not so philosophical Trump
has challenged America's ideals its
values what it believes about itself now
he must lead the country and heal it
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in New York